sometimes what makes an exam tough is
not just the questions on the paper but
how many other students you are
competing against
the exam that chinese students take to
gain entrance
into university was last year sat by
over 10 million students
that exam is known as the gao cow and
it's a huge deal
students spend years preparing for the
exam
often with very intense study schedules
and
hours of extra coaching outside of
school
the exam is sat once per year in june
and that day is taken very seriously
traffic is diverted away from exam halls
and
police patrol to keep the streets quiet
there are ambulances waiting outside
just in case of a nervous collapse
parents will gather to pick up their
children afterwards with flowers
to celebrate the fact that it's over it
is such
high stakes because the exam will give
students
a three-digit number which will often be
the
sole determinant of their acceptance
into university
the prestigious tier one universities
are highly sought after
as they may offer greater employment
opportunities
once graduated but their acceptance rate
may be as
low as 1 in 50 000 students
for many students doing well on the gao
cow
may be a ticket to a better life i have
a copy of the 2020 exam here
and i'll go through a few of the
questions just to show you what it is
like
the exam consists of compulsory sections
on chinese math and a foreign language
often english and electives from physics
chemistry biology or history geography
or politics
and it takes nine hours over a couple of
days
some of the most notorious questions are
the essays
and i've translated a few of them here
this one
is pretty relevant and it's all about
coronavirus
they say that in the face of the
outbreak they have
adopted prevention and control measures
that people are staying at home
venues are closed and there is a safe
one metre between people they talk about
the role
of volunteers medical experts workers
and teachers
and even journalists in fighting the
virus
then the question says please synthesize
the above materials and write an
article with the theme of distance and
connection
in the epidemic and they are to write an
essay of at least
800 words on this topic it seems that
current affairs or
current politics are often essay
questions
but so are some poetic and more unusual
sounding ideas
this one for example was so lovely even
after passing through google translate
that i wanted to share it with you
people use their eyes to see others and
the world
but they cannot directly see themselves
as a whole
therefore in the journey of life we need
to look for all kinds of mirrors
constantly draw self-portraits to
examine ourselves
and try to answer what kind of person
am i what kind of life do i want to live
and what can i do how to live more
meaningfully
and other important issues the question
asks you to write an essay as if you are
writing a letter to freshmen
who are about to enroll in the first
year of high school
on this theme of being able to perceive
yourself
challenging but a pretty interesting one
since this is a physics and maths
channel
i'll also take a look at those questions
this is one of the 2020 math papers
in chinese even just from looking at the
symbols and pictures
you might be able to tell there are
quite a few word problems
as well as a lot of geometry logic
a little bit of calculus some
complex numbers and some
probability and statistics i google
translated question 5 to see that it
says
if the circle passing the point 2 1 is
tangent to the two coordinate axes
the distance from the center of the
circle to the straight line
two x minus y minus three
equals zero is what this is my
interpretation of what that looks like
a circle that passes through the point 2
1
and for which both the axes are tangent
we want to find the distance from the
center of the circle
which would be at 1 1
to this straight line and we'll take
that to mean the shortest distance
which will meet the line at a
perpendicular angle
we'll want to find the equation of this
line and to do that we'll use the
formula
y minus y one is equal to
m x minus x one
m or the gradient of this line will be
the
opposite reciprocal of the line that we
already know
and that gradient is two so the gradient
of our line will be minus one half
substituting ones for y one and x one
will get the equation to be y is equal
to
minus a half x plus
three over two the line we already know
could be rewritten as y is equal to
two x minus 3 so we can set these two
equations
equal to each other doing that will give
us
the point where they intersect those
coordinates
are x equals nine-fifths and y equals
three-fifths
now we just want to find the distance
between these two known points
to do that we will use the distance
formula which is the square root
of x2 minus x1 squared
plus y2 minus y1 squared
putting our coordinates into there and
doing a bit of rearranging
would find that the correct answer is b
two root five over five i think that the
math involved here is
reasonable to expect on entrance exams
in a lot of countries
there are quite a few steps to this one
though so it's a little tricky
but i think it's worth remembering that
this exam
is not so much a certification or a
test that you have learned what you've
been taught at school
instead this is a ranking system
it doesn't really matter that you know
how to do all the math steps to solve
this problem
and you pull it all off without making a
mistake
it matters that you can get through the
entire exam
making as few mistakes as possible in
order to
rank high among the other students it
doesn't really matter how much you know
it matters how much everyone else knows
as well
moving on to physics this is the 2020
beijing
paper and the whole thing has been
google translated
there is a bit of atomic physics on the
first page
thermodynamics waves
some electromagnetism
including number eight where they've got
a picture of a small magnetic needle
hanging near a negatively charged rubber
disk
the disk rotates at high speed around
the central axis
and the small magnetic needle deflects
you're then asked to determine what's
going on
there's electronics a question about
molecular forces
friction and one about the conservation
of momentum and energy
question 14 is asking about a basketball
that is dropped from a height but is
given a bit of spin
and instead of falling straight down it
deviates from the vertical
and moves in a curve the second part of
this physics exam
seems to be more about some experimental
techniques
there are some classic questions about
experimental design
and following the scientific method the
first section was multi-choice
but the section requires written answers
there are 20 questions in here but a lot
of them have multiple parts
and some are pretty lengthy for this
physics paper i've shown you would get
90 minutes so it is still a race against
the clock
in conclusion as one would expect this
is a difficult exam
but i don't think that learning the
content matter
is really that far out of reach for most
students
in fact it is really dealing with the
insane competitiveness
that comes with trying to get all these
points without making mistakes
because even a tiny mistake could see
your ranking plummet
best wishes for anyone who is perhaps
preparing
for this exam or an exam like it
coming up in 2021 one day i hope you too
will be able to look at exams just for
fun
i do have a whole series looking at
exams across the world
so check out some of those videos in the
playlist at the end
thanks as always to my patreon
supporters for making these videos
possible
including a special shout out to today's
patreon cats of the day
strega and luna thanks for watching
and i hope to see you next time
[Music]
you